-Is it true -- you talked abou
driving across country
listening to music,
listening to the radio.
You back in the day
wanted to be a deejay?
This is one of your
childhood dreams?
-Yeah, childhood.
-Yeah.
-And childish.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But there was one guy
I was hooked on every night,
and, plus, we got to liste
to old-time radio dramas, too.
-Yeah.
-When I was a kid,
and anything
coming over the radio I love
But, yeah, there was something
about one guy
talking to you in the night.
And that's what I want--
up until I was about in college,
I thought maybe
I can pull this off.
-And when did you realize that
the door had shut on this dream?
[ Laughter ]
-It has?
-Yeah, I mean.
[ Laughter ]
It's all right.
[ Audience aws ]
I mean, I can probably
get you a podcast.
-Right now, this is from 1963,
and we're coming in --
-That would have
been really good.
-Yeah.
-Do you want to try
a little bit more?
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
"The Conners" -- you have
some exciting guest stars
coming up -- Katey Sagal.
-Katey Sagal is --
could be a possible girlfriend
We don't know yet.
-Yeah.
-And Danny Aykroyd was
on the other day.
-That's fantastic.
-Played at a poker game,
and he wrote his lines.
[ Laughs ]
So it was just, "Hang on.
What's Danny gonna do?"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So, now, I would imagine
most guest stars on the show
are not given the right
or encouraged
to write their own lines,
but Dan Aykroyd, obviously
a different deal?
-Yeah, yeah.
They let him go,
and it was pretty good.
-That's fantastic.
So, when --
so, you and Danny had obviousl
worked together before...
-Yeah.
-...doing "Blues Brothers"
stuff.
When is the last time you
had worked together with him
-Oh...
-Before this.
-Doing "SNL."
-Okay, gotcha.
-But I think it was still in
the '90s or -- no, it was 2002
-Yeah.
Yup, you guys are dressed up
like postmen.
-Yeah.
-In the monologue.
-To that show.
-I was there. So, yeah.
-[ Whistling ]
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no.
-During -- During "Update.
-You -- what was it like
the first time you met Dan
Do you remember meeting
Dan Aykroyd for the first time
-Yeah, I do.
I was drunk.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-No, the first time I met hi
was backstage at the Oscars,
and I got lubricated...
-Uh-huh.
-...and made an ass
out of myself.
But after that, I was
consciously trying to get hire
on the "Blues Brothers"
sequel in any capacity.
-Yeah.
-And we got to know each other
and I think we had a good time
-He's one of those people --
I don't know,
if this the case --
when you first met him, I mean
you know,
anybody looks up to him
because of how
we first laid eyes on him.
-Yeah.
-On those iconic first years
of the show.
He's so gracious and kind abou
the things that you have done.
I find it hard to --
-Yeah.
-It's very to hard to compliment
Dan Aykroyd
without him turning it aroun
and saying something nice
about somebody.
-Which he still does.
-Yeah.
-Which drives me nuts
'cause, like, "I didn't do -
yeah, but you, man,
you're so great."
[ Laughter ]
He -- you know,
first time you lay eyes on him
the guy's a force of nature.
-Yeah.
-And it -- equally --
equally gracious.
-Yeah, he's a wonderful guy.
-Yeah.
-That's very nice that
you got to do it.
And, obviously,
two different styles of show
You're doing "The Conners"
in front of a studio audience.
You're doing "Gemstones" -
you're shooting that
like a movie.
-People will come and see it
-What's that? [ Laughs ]
-We let --
I'll charge them 5 bucks a head.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you -- Do you like
being able to do both
at the same time?
-Yeah, I do.
-Yeah.
-It's a -- It's a stretch,
and it's -- it's just
because it's so different,
you don't get bored too easily
-Yeah. Is it --
-Never mind.
[ Laughter ]
-You have -- coming from lik
a theater background,
is it still fun to do stuf
in front of a live audience?
Do you like that feeling?
-It is.
They really overhype
these audiences these days
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Well, certainly ---
-You don't want to --
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But on a sitcom...
-Yeah.
-...on a sitcom particularly
Yeah.
-You're not going to be able
to time any --
any jokes.
[ Laughter ]
-That's true.
So, I guess at that point, yeah,
you're just trying
to get them out and --
-Whooooo.
[ Laughter ]
-I guess --
-Awwwwww!
-And that never happened to yo
on Broadway?
You were never getting
those reactions?
-I had a guy --
I did a Broadway show
a couple years ago,
and the date --
the night before we opened
they let people
in the front row.
This guy says,
"I love you, John Goodman.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait --
-And they had --
they had drinks on the stage
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
-Wait, so this is the beginnin
of the play
he's saying,
"I love you, John Goodman?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-And that is -- that's --
I mean, that's definition
breaking the fourth wall.
-Yeah. "I would like to breaking
his fourth neck."
[ Laughter ]
-How do you get through
something like that?
-You just do it --
look at the other guys onstage
and -- and they can see
you're panicked.
[ Laughter ]
We got through it.
It seemed like it was
an hour long.
-Sure.
-This guy doing it.
-Do you ever --
have you ever been in a case
where, during intermission
you've said,
"Hey, there's a guy
in the front row saying,
'I love you, John Goodman.
Is there anything
you can do about that?"
-No.
-Okay.
-Because there's nothing you
can do about it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-They don't --
that's an extreme case.
They usually just talk
or do their candy wrappers..
-Uh-huh.
-...or text or -- you know
-Do you see --
is it very obvious
when you see the blue light of
someone's phone on their face?
-Absolutely.
-Yeah.
-I would imagine
that would be --
I think the thing they shoul
tell people is not just,
"Don't use your phones" --
they should all say,
"Also, the actors
will know you're doing it.
-Yeah.
-'Cause I think, like, that --
I think everybody thinks
they can just sneak a peak
at their phone
and forget that
there's a giant -- yeah.
-Yeah, they got
that face going...
[ Laughter ]
-But not John Goodman --
"John Goodman is on to you."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-Yeah.
-"We're gonna get you."